just have thrilling that was it was fun
Lisa Kudrow remembers one of her most
iconic roles Phoebe this year marks the
25th anniversary of the show what do you
remember most about filming the show
with the pilot you know I think it's 25
years like to write now since we
finished the pilot and got picked up or
something yeah and just how thrilling
that was everyone we were like I don't
know like little puppy dogs just you
know like climbing all over each other
and playing and playing games and wanted
to be together all the time it was fun
will you watch it if you see it on TV or
when's the last time you watched it up
and say I don't know the last time I
don't watch it if it's on yeah I might
not like myself so I'd rather not risk
that
[Music]
Lisa's latest project while she's still
making us laugh this time in the new
comedy book smarts but you to have
especially well probably just do a
Korean face mask I don't need to know
all the words this movie is about female
friendship and I feel like you have that
with your girl squad that you post on
social media did shooting this movie
kind of remind you of those real-life
friendships of yours yeah of course you
know in a way it did yeah it made me
think of Romy and Michele too that even
though they were idiots these girls are
really smart it's a different time
completely different tone but that it's
you know ultimately about best friends
name one person whose life was so much
better because they broke a couple of
rules ah so he broke our rules Rosa
Parks naman else wasn't being god damn
it
[Music]